un homme qui se libèrent jean marie
villemin a parlé aujourd'hui devant les
assises de dijon en principe la journée
était consacrée à l'audition de
personnalité mais tout a été modifié
lorsque l'accusé du procès a raconté son
drame son histoire sa vie dominique
verdeilhan bruno girodon
l'homme qui s'exprime devant la cour est
avant tout un père celui de grégory
meurtri inconsolable sa voix se brise
s'étrangle jean marie villemin debout
ferme les yeux comme pour mieux dérouler
le film de son drame dans une atmosphère
pesante la salle revit elle aussi la
sphère 16 octobre 84 grégory dit au
revoir à son père c'est la dernière
image que j'ai de lui dans le
rétroviseur jean marie villemin sanglote
s'accroche au montant de la vitre pare
balles puis c'est l'insoutenable image
un corps sous une couverture il était
beau il ne paraissait pas mort celui qui
a fait ça je veux la voir avant la
justice at il promis ce soir là la mise
en liberté de la roche ce fut un choc
c'est comme si on tuait une deuxième
fois mon enfant face au président 800
qui brandit l'armé du crime jean marie
villemin raconte les quatre tentatives
qui ont précédé l'assassinât je voulais
également levé muriel et marie-ange
marie-ange c'est quelque chose je le
sais je le sens la roche m'a dit c'est
pas moi j'ai tiré au jugé ensuite je me
suis précipité à la clinique retrouver
christine je ne voulais pas qu'elle
l'apprenne par les radios
bernard laroche coupable jean marie
villemin n'a aucun doute aujourd'hui
encore il assume sa responsabilité même
s'il reconnaît avoir été conditionné par
la presse d'abord dont il dit elle nous
a fait autant de mal que les gendarmes
par l'incompétence d'un magistrat par
les policiers aussi qui ont porté leurs
soupçons sur christine jean marie
villemin n'a eu aujourd'hui qu'un seul
souci faire oublier l'accusé pour ne se
présenter quand victime